jean marc sylvestre bonjour bonjour
olivier heureux de vous retrouver dans
la matinale de rtl france alors dans son
discours programme pour accompagner les
mesures sanitaires renforcés emmanuel
macron a donc indiqué que la france
était parti pour faire 6 % de croissance
en 2021
c'est important alors deux questions
est-ce que c'est réaliste et comment
va-t-on faire
oui alors vous savez je crois qu'ils
émanent de gens qu'on est allé plus loin
que prévu dans l'obligation de
vaccination
et c'est vrai que les mesures annoncées
sont un peu durs paraître un peu
violente
il ya une seule raison c'est pour
préserver la reprise de l'économie et
même la relance de cette économie tout
son discours a été construit autour de
cet objectif il a démarré sur un
diagnostic de la situation économique en
reprenant la prévision de croissance de
6% vous avez raison mais c'est une
prévision de croissance qui est partagé
par la plupart des centres d'analysé de
recherche ou de france mx et la bce et
même l' ocde alors il arrondit parce que
de le dernier chiffre officiellement
donné par bercy il ya à peu près deux
semaines tablaient sur 5,9 pour cent
mais enfin on dirait qu'il est dans le
consensus 1 6% alors ça peut paraître
important vous avez raison mais tous les
pays développés dans le monde change sur
des prévisions de croissance très forte
la france est à 6% l'union européenne
est à 4,3 pour cent l'allemagne est à
3,5
un peu plus bas parce que l'allemagne
était moins descendu que nous
la chine en revanche grand gagnant lui
18 4% de croissance les états unis grand
gagnant 6 lui pour sortent donc la
prévision française
elle n'est pas aberrant car d'un point
de vue économique d'autant que l'état
français est l'un de ceux qui a le plus
soutenu son économie tous les
indicateurs actuellement sont au vert on
en parle peu mais c'est vrai la
consommation elle est booming
l'investissement il est booming l'emploi
l'epargne pouvoir d'achat le commerce
extérieur et même la bourse qui n'a
d'ailleurs jamais flanché pendant toute
cette période alors tous les moteurs de
la croissance sont à l'ubs et ils se
sont allumés où ils se sont rallumées g
qu'on a chanté que la polémique pouvais
être battu en brèche et c'est bien le
problème finalement que le problème dont
on n'était pas économique
le problème il était dans la crise
sanitaire on a senti que dès la sortie
où la perspective de sortie de cette
crise sanitaire
confinement ont été levées et bien il ya
eu un rebond une reprise de l'activité
mais jean-marc est-ce que c'est tenable
et solide parce qu'il ya quand même des
secteurs qui ont souffert vous avez
raison vous avez raison pour répondre à
la question
trois choses 1 la reprise paraît très
forte mais on revient aussi de très loin
je rappelle qu'en 2020 on a reculé de
plus de 9% en france mais tous les pays
ont reculé dans ces proportions là donc
il faut rattraper et c'est un rattrapage
donc ça repart mais on aura du mal à la
fin de l'année a retrouvé le niveau
d'avant la crise on va sans doute
retrouver le niveau de la crise à ce
rythme là au début de l'année prochaine
2021 et donc on aura du mal à rattraper
très vite tout ce qu'on a perdu
on a enfin eu beaucoup emprunté pour
soutenir l'activité
il faudra continuer de soutenir cette
activité parce que il ya effectivement
des secteurs qui ont du mal c'était
d'ailleurs des secteurs qui était déjà
malade avant la crise il ya des
mutations à financer le digital
l'écologie les transitions énergétiques
et tous âges tout ça va demander des
moyens importants financier on a donc
besoin d'une croissance forte pour
rembourser la dette
faut pas se raconter une histoire il
faudra rembourser la dette est ce que ça
veut dire qu'on a besoin de cette
croissance forte pour sortir de la crise
oui c'est pas un objectif c'est un
besoin c'est une nécessité absolue c'est
bien comme ça que emmanuel macron a
donné chief c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'apparition d'une nouvelle
vague épidémique a aussi fortement
inquiété les chefs d'entreprises et les
gouvernements le variant l'indien
emmanuel macron c est perçue peut-être
un peu tard qu'il était en risque d'être
obligé de confirmer davantage si on ne
vaccine est pas toute la population
c'est à dire si on ne mettait pas à
l'abri tout le monde les mesures
renforcées sur l'obligation vaccinale
sur le pass sanitaires sont les seuls et
les derniers moyens pour limiter
finalement a cassé puis des mythes et
permettent à l'économie de tourner on a
besoin de ces 6 % pour retrouver une vie
normale
on a besoin de ces 6 % de croissance
pour rembourser les dettes
j'ajouterai que le président lui même a
besoin des 6% pour se présenter à la
présidentielle parce que l'activité
économique et social qui quoi qu'on en
dise va être un facteur clé dans le chef
gordon dans
élections ce qui m'étonne moi dans cette
affaire vous savez c'est qu'on est quand
même pris conscience de la nécessité
vaccinale un peu tard je crois que le
président a cédé à la prudence politique
portois il s'est essayé de s'adapter à
tout ça parce que la gestion était
submergé de critiques notamment sur le
thème de la liberté individuelle attaqué
on a encore entendu dans votre journal
je pense que la majorité de l'opinion a
envie de vivre normalement et si la nuit
normale passe par la vaccination
il ya l'opinion publique sera d'accord
on a bien vu d'ailleurs la précipitation
avec laquelle les français ont demandé
des rendez vous on a bien vu depuis 48
heures c'est afflux de demandes pour
être vaccinés ça veut bien dire que la
mesure était quand même attendu merci
beaucoup jean-marc l'édito échos de jean
marc sylvestre à retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux